Film Courage: Zach, when did
you start writing screenplays?
Zach Zerries, Screenwriter/Author:
I started in NYU film school so a while ago but
it was actually I wrote my first it wasn't I was
writing short scripts in film school and then
my first script I wrote right after I graduated
and that was part of your thesis was to do
these shorts no so we were more I wasn't in
the dramatic writing program at NYU we were in
the film production tv production major so to
speak we focused more on producing directing we
did obviously take a writing class or two but
that was more sort of geared towards short short
films that we would shoot ourselves or produce
or at that time video we had the tv production
but for the most part no I didn't I had always
been curious about writing but I really and when
I got to once I got out of film school and through
film school I really developed a affinity for
writing and editing and you were sort of the
beginning of the process and the
end the process but I always thought
the most creative parts of the process
of making films or making television so
again it was mostly short stuff through
film school but then when I got out
I started thinking alright let me give that this
writing thing a go and I wrote my first script so
I think I had started on it maybe during film
school but then once I was out right when I
finished after graduation I finished it and
after graduation did you stay in New York city
for about a year I worked some
jobs and I had my family was there
and I had a girlfriend at the time who I was
very serious with and once I sort of realized
that New York wasn't the place to be and that I
had spoken to some friends of mine and and fellow
Tisch alum who were out on the west coast it
became clear that I needed to to move to move
out here to la and and start my film career this
is where everyone and everything was at the time
it's since changed a lot and involved but back
then that's when it became clear that New York
really wasn't happening on the grand scale that
or to further my career at the time in the film
and tv business so I moved and when you came here
did you have any sort of not buyer's remorse but
did you did you have a couple sleepless nights
where you said maybe this isn't for me I don't
remember I think I have I was very fortunate
because both my parents were very supportive
in my decision they had both been advertising
executives and both kind of always marched to
their own beat so they wanted they wanted me
to sort of pursue my goals career goals and so
moving here I definitely felt that I had
their support I've missed them very much
but no I don't think I ever had any sleepless
nights I at times I thought oh maybe I will move
back one day because I did miss New York but
after a while I just became accustomed to la
and and realized that I was more probably while
New York was always home I always felt that my
soul belonged here in California and Los Angeles
how many screenplays did you write before you
wrote take back well I wrote take back probably
in the year of 2012 so before that I had written
probably about ten I'd say anywhere from eight
to ten off the top of my head so yeah it was
interesting story it was my manager at the time
suggested I write something a low-budget action
film and I believe it or not was in church
I attended this church service once and
this woman was speaking about she was she ran
this worldwide organization that helped women
and helped them recover and build their
lives back and I just remember I literally
had the conversation with my my manager like
suggesting I write a low budget action film and
this sermon literally a week later I'm like oh
that's interesting and it kind of went from there
but but yeah it was it was a I would say probably
a good eight to ten scripts before I wrote
take back and these were feature scripts
yeah they were feature I had written some
I had no I hadn't quite started doing pilots I had
I had written I subsequently wrote some pilots but
this was my first yeah this was yeah everything
else had been features up until that point
and so were you using a screenwriting
software when you started these eight to
ten scripts or were you doing it just
sort of like in a word document page
no I always I always used final draft I think
back in film school and or and and maybe my first
script I used what was called I think it was
called script thing it was an NYU professor of
mine he had all it was final draft I think was
still was around at the time I'm pretty sure but
he had us using script thing and you know it was
fine it was just like final draft but and I don't
even know if it's still around I'm assuming
it's not but after that I went to final draft
but I always I always plot my story on word
doc I always structure plan everything on my
word document on word doc before I go into the
actual writing of the script and that could take
months before I feel comfortable with that
that blueprint before I put it before I
go and start actually writing action and
dialogue was take back your original script
yes take back was the original script and
again just it was I should say inspired by
this story and I'll give you the the story
that I heard was there this this this woman who
ran this worldwide organization that helped
girls she had heard about this or had taken
in this young woman who I think was about maybe
18 or 19 at the time and she was dating this guy
and she was dating this man for a few months
and one night he took her to like this bar and
she was subsequently drugged and then this was in
st louis and she woke up in this just sort of very
decrepit abandoned warehouse
somewhere with other girls
and was basically kept there for I think three
to four years yeah and it was this horrific story
where she was kept there and as miracle would
have it one day her captor or one of her captors
I guess left the key near her because she was
basically chained to a bed three or four years and
john's would come in and do their thing and
she was chained to this bed and miraculously
this key dropped I guess one of the captors key
to her cuffs dropped on the bed or near the bed
she got it freed herself and escaped and alerted
the cops and so that was really sort of after that
was the the story that sort of drove me to write
the script like if there was this woman who was
taken held and then basically she wound up
escaping and taking revenge on her trying to
live a normal life her past came back to haunt her
in the form of the man who kidnapped her who she
thought was dead and then she's got a basically
now she has this family that she has to protect
so that was sort of the the bare bones
for the story that I came up with and
again subsequently went through a number of
drafts till it got to the shooting version
does your process change every time you write a
screenplay or has it evolved or sometimes you'll
do it one way and you'll plot and you'll outline
and other times you'll start another way great
question and I know everyone has a different
process about when you're developing a script
or an idea for me I feel like I've gotten
that old adage of work smarter not harder
I think that ultimately boils down to knowing
to having a really solid the first process is
getting the log line down where you have that the
log line and you have that hint of irony it's it's
just boiling it down to a sentence that you
can pitch to somebody like what's it about
and people get it right away from there
once I think you have that locked in
then it's a matter of really breaking it out
into the main components of the story and the
structure for me that is where I've really become
a lot more fastidious with my process of knowing
like again what's the hard turn what's the
what's that inciting incident how does it
affect the character what's sending them off to
that to that first act turn point turning point
then from there to the bin point and then intact
three and how they're changing along the way
I think it was I was I'm sure like every writer
obviously read the blake snyder save the cat and
I think honestly that's that's probably the
most comprehensive book on screenwriting I
would I recommend that anyone who's looking
to break in I always tell them to get save
the cat save the cat goes to the movies because
I think blake snyder was really on to something
so I really do follow I believe it's the
16 major beats that he laid out in there
and and their purpose and for me that really
I think I was going in that direction before
I read the blake snyder novel but certainly after
and and and he was also such an inspiring writer
blake snyder was but getting a good idea of how to
really lay out the story and how to structure it
that to me is is again is the most important
part of the process I think once you have your
log line and your structure you know the writing
it's probably about 60 70 percent of the process
I think the actual writing is about 30 percent
because if you everything lined up where your
character is going their journey it's going to
make things a lot easier for you and of course
things will always change and you have to be
open and flexible I know some people who write
30 page outlines 40 page outlines I usually try to
keep it between 6 and 8 pages just because I feel
like if you're with an outline like that you sort
of lose some of the momentum the creativity where
if you have a good idea and you're you really have
a good structure in place knowing what what scene
comes after what scene comes after what scene and
it's this snowball that keeps rolling up if you
keep it tight in those first in that that outline
and then from there you can use that and then
just transfer it to the final final draft or the
actual script I think then you have good momentum
to keep to keep the flow the creative flow going
for sure and giving leaving yourself room for some
flexibility because things will always come up and
certainly has in anything that I've ever written
and how long did you work on the log line for
take back the log line that one actually came
fairly quickly I don't recall because
it's been some time but I think once
I think after really sort of attending
that particular church service
it it came pretty quickly and again I pitched it
to my manager at the time and gave him a very like
bare-bones idea where I wanted the
story to go and she said yeah go for it
it he was always mine he still is my
barometer and of of we still throw ideas
off the wall at each other and and I think it
he definitely was instrumental in giving me good
sort of good feedback on the log line and then
where the story was going to go do you remember
the exact log line the exactly well I remember
the I remember the quick elevator pitch was always
going to be taken it was going to be taken
meets a history of violence I always loved
a history of violence for I just thought it was it
was based on a graphic novel but I loved the idea
of this guy who is he's he's living this very
seemingly quiet life in the middle of america
and he commits this act of heroism and then his
past comes back to get him and we're still not
sure is it really him and then we I don't know
if anyone is seated I want to spoil the movie
but it really was for me I basically saw it as if
to be as simplistic as possible a female version
of a history of violence so it was I guess at
the time again this is going back a few years
the original log line would have been something
like you know a young woman living a seemingly
happy existence in this small town commits
commits act of heroism that brings evil forces
from her her past life if you will will you ever
write a screenplay without outlining first no
I know and again my my process is I
have my process it's a lot of people
have their way of doing things some people can
just I've known writers who've been successful
who are just able to they have it in their head
and they're just able to put it down on paper
write go right to final draft and put it on paper
now for me I have to be again I really have to
know how those beats turn those the main beats
turn into story and really what my character's
journey is and where they start and where they end
and I know it seems pretty rudimentary but it's
it's really for me yeah I don't I don't think
I could ever do that I would be lost you know
there's as I'm sure a lot of your viewers know
you've you've heard of second act tell where you
you could write a great first act but then just
get your character gets completely lost in the
second act and that that more ass that when you
haven't been when you haven't plotted it on this
again this just applies to me knowing really where
where they're supposed to go you have to be their
their guide you have to be the character's guide
and if you don't know if you don't have again
like some kind of blueprint and play blue
blueprint in place it's not going to again this
is in my opinion it it doesn't it doesn't help me
again there's there's as I said earlier there's
I always find you can I try to be as flexible as
possible the story especially after you've written
it and you get feedback from colleagues and others
and sometimes a script may just not work and
you may write it and you think this isn't
this isn't cutting it I have to go back
and re-examine and and maybe rip it apart
and try it again and sometimes you just have
to move on it may just not be the right time
you may get inspired by another idea but yeah
the the I would never I would never not outline
any kind of writing I do I always have to have
a blueprint in place is discipline and order
something that you actually enjoy yes I try to
write anywhere between four and six hours a day
I think after sometimes longer it depends I
can go eight to ten hours before I start really
I think six hours is pretty much where is my
average where I can just I can go to before
I start I'm like I think my brain is I need to
just throw in the towel for the day but yes no
I'm usually up pretty early usually writing I'd
say anywhere between seven and eight and then
I'll work to the late morning take a breath break
do a little exercise have breakfast and then work
again until the early evening that's generally
my structure and abided by that for a while
I know you talked about martial arts yeah and
that's something that's part of your life yeah
I know martial arts is a big part of my life and
I've been do I've been training for over 10 years
and this sort of ties into everyone's process is
different it was always this not so much in our
community but in in other I've heard of other
people who train in martial arts saying one might
be better than the other and if you're doing if
you're doing some martial art it's great because
I feel like they're so wonderful for the mental
physical and spiritual side of someone to help
them as it is with writing everyone has their own
process and whatever it might be whatever it might
however you do something or however you feel
is and if that works for you then god bless
but but yeah and again as far as martial arts yes
I think martial arts is wonderful for discipline
for self-esteem and you're also really I think
tapping into similar emotions sometimes as you
are with writing there's there is definitely a
spiritual side I think to to martial arts and
I think as it is with writing you're getting
in touch with certain emotions in a spiritual
sense creative sense and if that makes any that
makes any sense but yeah I feel that in a lot
of ways they they run and there's a parallel
to both of them for sure one helps the other
right speaking of spiritual I think the writer of
the exorcist and forgive me I'm blanking on his
name and I enjoy was it william peter blotti yes
I think so I bought it right and he said there's
a rhythm or was that the writer of straws I don't
know I read I read the exorcist and I read jaws
the books I think it was william peter blotti who
wrote the exorcist I thought so yeah and he said
and and he was a very spiritual man and he said
that that there was a good writing has a rhythm
yeah and I was wondering if if there's almost
a correlation between that and then the martial
arts because you're you're getting into some
sort of a flow absolutely for me aside from
the joy that I get from my wife and my
my daughter and my stepchildren there are
and family when New York sports teams are actually
good there's a there's a there's definitely
a high I get from from writing when you're
investing a character and you're really
pushing their story and you're locked in and
you're your character almost speaking for you
and I've heard a lot of other writers talk about
that and I think early in my career I'm like
what what are you talking about but I think
after you've done it for a while and you again
have a good sense of where again you have a good
structure in place and where your story is going
the characters in a sense will start talking for
you what where they they know you stop leading
them and they start leading you in a way which
is which is pretty neat and I think that is what
for me what we hope to achieve and martial arts
absolutely there are breakthroughs when you're in
tungsuda which is my martial art we have we
do we perform youngs which are essentially
improvised fighting forms and there's
something to be said when you really
reach that level when you're really
connected when your mind body and spirit
are all connected it's it's again it's that that
just that rush of euphoria that you really and and
it is a blend of creativity and it's a blend of
discipline it's a it's a blend of focus that all
comes together and it's it's you you really derive
a triumphant feeling from it there's no doubt and
it's I know that again if I if I leave the office
and I'm really thrilled with something I wrote
I have a bounce of my step similar martial arts
if I really feel like I got to form down well
and then of course are the days where you're like
I didn't have I wasn't really on it and I'm one to
beat myself up although I've gotten better thanks
to martial arts about not beating myself as up as
much as I used to but there's definitely there
there's definitely links sure and again in my
opinion between the two and I've been doing both
for a long time we were joking off camera while
setting up that you don't have to be the writer
that has like several scotches and his chances
you can be the discipline writer that's like you
said up yeah at five and having whatever chai
or yeah no it's funny yeah that story I was yeah
it was that story derived from the fact that my
my late dad he it was actually we were having a
discussion shortly before he passed away he was
I told him that I was going out with some friends
too we were gonna have some scotch and smoke some
cigars which was a mistake because my dad my
dad said he said oh god he said I could just
see you in your apartment there writing with a
bottle of scotch and and cigar going all night
and and that to me that's I'm not a big drinker
I rarely smoke cigars but yeah that's sort of the
I guess almost like a parody of writers from the
that or or stigma of writers maybe that still
exists like my dad was probably old-fashioned
in some ways but those writers from the that
that bygone era of the the golden era film
as they said 30s 40s 50s up in their little
I guess what were they bungalows writing until
all odd hours of the night drinking scotch smoking
cigarettes or cigars but no I my my process is two
cups of coffee and through the day and I'm good
no alcohol infusion or or cigarettes or cigars so
yeah yeah what's your typical writing day usually
I tend to get up anywhere between maybe quarter
to six 6 30. again I try not to wake my wife
and I get that cup of coffee to get my
fix my caffeine fix and then I'm usually
writing in our we have a guest small
guesthouse I'm usually in the back there
for me I like I enjoy reading the newspaper in
the morning for about 30 minutes just to get my
brain sort of drinking coffee getting my brain
going just I'm an avid reader I always have been
and I feel like reading really starts stimulating
the mind along with the caffeine but it gets me
going so yeah I usually so again I try
to be working by about 7 30 or 8 o'clock
and again until I'll work to the late morning take
a break just to get my head right and then come
back and probably the early afternoon and I can
go till late afternoon sometimes so that's usually
my that's usually in my routine as you said be
asked before is that it's there's definitely
there's a rhythm to the rhythm I feel especially
when I'm when I'm writing and creating
and when you say you're reading the paper is
this an actual newspaper yes I know I have I have
friends and my wife still joke me I do have some
traditions that I have not parted ways with and
yes it's a it's a it is a actual paper I try to
I really try to avoid the screen as much as I can
because I'm on it all day so yeah when I can
usually get you know anything in in print
it makes just to start my day to get again
get those juices flowing get my brain working
I find that writing really or reading excuse me
really helps the writing for sure and again doing
it not on a screen are you reading the first pages
of this yeah it's usually I may I'm a longtime
wall street journal fan and I happen to
read pretty much everything throughout
I'm a fan of their reportage I think
it's pretty much down the middle I know
not to get into we're a very divided country
right now but I happen to really appreciate the
fact that they're fairly down the middle and not
too biased one way or the other and for me that's
that's important so yeah I mean knowing what's
going on in the world and in our country again
as has really really helps me and I think helps
my writing because you never know where that next
idea is coming from I think a lot of my ideas over
the years have come from magazines or or articles
in the paper not necessarily wall street journal
I read all kinds of I used to read news magazines
I wrote a script about a militia group that was
derived from a I believe it was a newsweek article
in my chiropractor at the time her office she
had this newsweek article on the rise of militias
probably this was around 2010 or so so I wrote
another I wrote another script about a pirate
hunter in the southeast asia which was based on a
smithsonian article so I always find and I've had
I had another idea for a script that was based
on a story recently in the wall street journal so
that's where I derive a lot of my my ideas from
when I'm writing when I'm from my film ideas
anyway and then of course take back was hearing
something in a sermon but it was it was a I guess
it I it's a news related type story so I always
found that finding stories in the news you know
again it it I've known people that
have just been able to conjure up
great stories in their mind and I've done that a
couple times but I feel like for me just reading
about someone and again this is not you know
stealing the article or anything it's just
coming up like oh that's an interesting topic
and then sort of making it my own it wasn't
never necessarily articles about a particular
person it was about a particular subject and and
that definitely helped definitely help me
develop my own stories and give me that sort
of that germ of the idea to then take it in
the direction I wanted to and make it my own
who do you model your screenwriting after I
don't model it after anyone per se I I've been
I definitely have some people of influence who I
think are phenomenal writers and obviously their
track record speaks for themselves themselves
but I've always been obviously william goldman
who he's the godfather of screenwriting tony
gilroy brian helgeland david capp those guys
when you read one of their scripts I
mean they're just on a whole other level
and I was I was always especially I would say tony
gilroy especially because I feel like he writes
some just brilliant action and yeah those
those those screenwriters I think for me were
set he definitely left a an impression and how
to write just an entertaining script because
I think sometimes the way I try to write is
that I want people to keep turning pages I
know this might be the process for many
writers or what they set out to do but
I really do think it's important is after all you
want your you want your audience to keep going and
I've always believed in just being as sparse
and concise as possible in my descriptions and
letting the dialogue move the story along and not
getting so so wrapped up in smart ass dialogue
but just letting the characters again take
the story in the direction and drive drive
the story especially if you're writing action or
or adventure or thriller type genre films do you
ever subscribe to the idea I know some people
have said don't don't delve too much into one
artist's work because then you might end up
emulating them too much and you wouldn't even
realize it or or no there is definitely some truth
to that reading reading a whole a whole array of
of scripts and writers definitely helps inform you
better I feel like for some of the scripts that I
wrote I always again if I'm if I'm if somebody's
to write an action script and they want somebody
to just sort of again to be a guy to somebody a
reference for them I would I would always say look
at a gilroy a helga land or a david kept script
because again I feel like they're I should say
that for me pacing is really important I want to
keep the story moving along at a fluid pace and
I feel like those guys like another steve's alien
steve's alien I remember said something that that
left a le has has left a lasting impression I read
this years ago where he said I will cut and cut
and cut until if I cut one again I'm paraphrasing
here I cut one word the whole scene falls apart so
just being able to really make your scenes as lean
as possible and in your writing and to keep it
paced and to keep it moving forward and keep the
story moving forward the character moving forward
and I and I do think yes I it's good I mean read
read all tony gilroy scripts but obviously I would
suggest reading a whole lot of other scripts
and and getting a sense of that and again just
just try to stay true to your voice because it
is easy if you read one particular author or
one particular screenwriter you definitely
could fall in the trap of subconsciously
you're writing like them and I think again they're
good reference points but you just have to again
find your own voice and find your own
rhythm and pattern and stay true to that
do you remember the first script that
you read it was probably in the late 90s
and I want to say it may have been chinatown
it may have been chinatown it's been a while so
yeah it may have been chinatown or even saving
private ryan which was a amazing script and
chinatown was obviously robert town just one of
the masters as well but I think it may have very
well been chinatown where did you get it in 1998
it would have been it would have been it would
have been through NYU we they had a fairly they
had a library that you could go and take scripts
out and read and so that's probably where I got
it and I having having been had been a fan of that
film growing up and being a k when I was a kid my
mom and dad again were very liberated they let us
get away with watching what now I think parents
maybe over protect but again the 80s were the
80s were a different time but we were my mom and
dad exposed us to many of the great movies like I
might I first watched french connection which is
my favorite film of all time bar none when I was I
think nine it was running on the on the local fox
affiliate in New York and my dad had loved that
movie and he said it's a great film and we watched
it commercials and all and it's funny because I
think that summer it may have been the summer of
87 or 86 it was on like probably every other week
it was maybe this is the 80s and they it was
a summer film they just kept running over time
over the the course of the summer or that period
of time but it was yeah I really loved it and not
long after that we saw the godfather and and so
I think I had probably seen chinatown and the
godfather both godfather films and in chinatown
are in french connection before I was 10.
so I was exposed to film from a really young age
and yeah that was so yeah so that was and and
your your question about chinatown was
yeah I probably got that script at the
at the NYU library how did you learn story
structure I learned it in initially learned
it at NYU I had a screenwriting profession
a professor by the name of stephen siegel
who really he was a he was tough but fair and
he was a stickler for not just story structure
but format and to this day I still
have his voice in my head a little bit
when I'm writing I became maybe at
times too wedded to certain formatting
but he really taught me the bare
bones of how to write a script I think
when I was young again it was that urge just
to get to the just to start writing not to
really think about the story and plot it out I
think it became much clearer to me about how to
again story structure character development as I
as I got older and and got out of film school but
he definitely planted the seeds that I then sort
of sewed later on as I again evolved as a writer
when you left film school did you I know you said
that you realized at some point that New York was
probably not for you at the time right did you
think that you would get a job working in a
production company what was in your mind that you
as a career yeah I mean for me it was to just be
in the business and see where the day to see where
I could go I was pretty fortunate because when I
came out here I had a lot of interviews right
away I had so my first job out of NYU had been
at writers and artists which is was purchased
by paradigm probably maybe even 20 years at
this point but they were still like they had
a New York and an la office and they had a
nice stable of like james gandolfini at the
time was rep by them they had some other
fairly big name actors and the New York the New
York agents erect like they I think they actually
had may have had half the cast on sopranos so
they repped a lot of broadway and film tv actors
so I was my first job out of school when I moved
to la I initially was interviewing at management
companies and other agencies I knew I didn't want
to be an agent but I thought just getting the
experience and learning the business was
most important I worked at icm for about
a second it was literally a second it was
probably three days I worked for a very big
talent agent there and quickly realized that I was
just not gonna cut it so my roommate at the time
I was I remember walking out icm and
just breathing a sigh of relief because
I had I feel like a monkey had been off my back so
I'm like okay I know there's no way I'm gonna work
in the agency business at all or mat as a manager
that I just can't do it I'm not cut from that
cloth there's a certain type and I am not he or
she so my roommate at the time for whatever reason
he had been sent a job opportunity as a writer's
pa on this fox show at the time and I went in and
I interviewed I got the job and then the first day
my first day there the show is cancelled oh no so
it lasted a couple more weeks and it was they the
same production company was producing this comedy
and it was a sitcom that they are they were
developing it was an ed burns pilot and
I remember because it was the same company they
were saving on supplies so we brought the supplies
from I was at sony at the time I moved this
supplies to uh the cbs radford and I walked in
I said hey you guys are starting do you need a pa
your writer's pa they're like actually we need a
pa and I was like great here's my resume and I got
the job and I worked for about a month and I was a
night pa and I have to say like I've worked some
very interesting jobs but driving in la at night
was just this it was a it was a I don't want to
use the word mystical but it was it was definitely
an interesting experience because at that time
this was just I mean people had email but a lot
of executives and other writers wanted the actual
script delivered so I was going from pasadena to
as far out as I may have gone to malibu and this
was like I think I worked like 27 hours straight
but it was but it was wild it was fun like I
learned the lay of the land doing that at night
it was I was kind of on my own I was you know
driving probably 80 90 miles an hour in my
little chevy cavalier all around the town
but it was an experience and it was really it
was a lot of fun and I learned a lot and anyway
long story short that pilot was being shot and
I had a friend who was working at law and order
at the time and he said there's a writer's
writer's production assistant job open on
this new law and order show there it was criminal
intent and they said you are you interested in
I'm like yes I would love to because I
think this this pilot is ending and I
they're shooting the pilot it hadn't been picked
up at that point I was like yes if it's permanent
I love it and I wound up getting that job and I
was a law and art on the law worked on the law
and order shows for close to two years so I had
that background in television and then from there
I got into to research and I worked and working
at fox for many years as a research analyst
while I was still writing and it was my day
job but I always was able to find jobs that
supported my writing and and I was able to one
fed the other and yeah it was it was definitely
back to your question about the
business and and getting into it it was
it was definitely I always knew I wanted to
write and the but keeping an open mind on
the day job type led me to in a lot of different
directions and I had a time where I did temp and
attempt in marketing attempt in post-production
I worked in post-production I had an array of
different jobs and while I was still writing and
always always putting in the time and and that's
now is has definitely paid off but anyone who's
coming out and trying to get in the film business
I would say sign up with a temp agency work in
an agency or management company you may like it
maybe writing's not for you and you may decide you
are cut from that cloth to be an agent but it's a
I think it's just a matter of keeping as open mind
as possible and learning all different aspects of
the business while you're continuing to hone
your craft did the driving job the driving pa
job did that inspire any stories for scripts no
no it was it was just again I was pretty new to
la so I was still like again just I think I was
just focused on learning the terrain at the time
and I do remember I was working on a script
that I again earlier in my career one of the
mistakes I made was working working scripts
over and over and over again until it's like
look enough you've written this written 20
different drafts it's all coming out the same
maybe just need to put this in the drawer
and step away and start go for something else
beating your head against the wall isn't I don't
obviously is not productive and I know that
if you have a really great idea and you love
it and you're you're you're really wedded to it
that's great but sometimes the best thing
you can do for a script that you're wedded to
and you really want to tell but it's
not working is just to take a step back
and put it away and start and work on something
else I know again early in my career I should have
done that with a few scripts where I'm like I'm
just focusing I'm beating my head against the wall
and and that was that was about working harder
not smarter at the time and in hindsight those
scripts the best thing those things those scripts
could have used was was better structure better
better plotting and more and a better outline
and I hadn't really fully evolved to that place
where I was able to really put to to to write
an effective outline and and really explore
the story that way I think I was just so quick
to go right to jump right into the screenplay
and it leaves yourself open to a lot of problems
do you believe characters drive plot yes
oh okay I was gonna say or is it the other
way around it sounds like you you're very
yes it's it's imperative they obviously
go hand in hand but if you don't have
again that intriguing character that we're going
to root for and we care about then it just is
going to fall apart for you in your story that's
just again my opinion it's interesting because
I feel like there have been some movies and shows
made recently and they they go for this anti-hero
and again if done we were talking earlier one of
my favorite shows of all time is californication
and you have this anti-hero who is you
he's a rogue he's this this charming rogue
and he is so self-destructive and he just gets
in his own way all the time but he's got heart
and he loves his daughter and he's
in love with his estranged girlfriend
and he as as infuriating as he can be he still
keeps us watching because again we do want to see
what he's going to do next because he's capable of
anything but that we really do care about him not
just because he's hilarious he's funny and he's a
he's wizard with words he's a writer in the series
but he is but he's just there's something just
that we we care about him at the end of it all
through those seven seasons and I feel like
at times I lately I've watched some shows
and again it's just my opinions that I feel
like I'm not really on the side of any I'm
not really rooting for anyone and I think I
know the audience wants people to root for
so if you don't have that character developed in a
way that we're gonna you're gonna really have and
again not all stories need the character needs
an arc things do happen to them but I feel like
at the end of it all we do want to see something
happen to our character him or her that changes
them and that we really even if they start at
the place where they're a loathsome character
by the end we want to see them redeemed in some
way I think that's just our natural inclination
as humans I think we do we do love a good in a
way not a redemption story but seeing a character
or or character is redeemed so yeah I feel like
to just the the most important thing you can do
is again as as I referenced earlier having those
beats those beats are for your character what
are the changes to your character yes it
obviously goes hand in hand with the plot
but how is your character being changed by this
story and how are they subsequently changing
the story I think every beat really does hinge
on their decisions and what their what they're
choosing to do in in the story without a doubt you
said earlier you really like to have the pacing
good and to really push the story
along yeah has it ever happened where
someone's looked at your script and said what the
character's changing too soon slow it down or vice
versa sure I I yeah there's definitely that over
the years where I've probably gotten that note
it has happened I don't recall on which
particular script but it has happened for sure
and I think it's easy especially in early drafts
when you write an earlier draft and you're wanting
to get it down you've plotted it you have it
set you have the story set you have your turns
they're hard turns your your people looked at
it they're like this is a really good outline
time to go right where yeah where it
sometimes doesn't always translate to
you may start doing the character may start
developing a little too soon I think if that's
the case then you kind of have to go back
to the outline and just that's why having
good structure is important is going back
to the outline and using it as a reference
saying okay here's where I need that character to
change and etc so yeah I I do I do think it's um
it's it's one of those things where yeah you
there are a lot of times that again earlier
drafts where you may be having a character
evolve too soon rather than giving them
her a letting it gestate a little bit more
Zach what if that outline fails you what if
you outline and then you get to the screenplay
and then it doesn't work great question um
i I think that it's sort of one of
those things where I I'll say this
it's important I I've been part of I've
been part of many writers groups over
the years and I've recently been part of
another one for the last couple of years
I feel like if you have a good if you have a
writer's group in place that that can really help
you see certain things fellow writers I should say
that sometimes can can really help and can steer
your and and I always feel like those sessions
that I have with them provide invaluable feedback
I don't always use all of it but sometimes
I walked away with like that's a great idea
more to the point about whether an
outline fails and the script doesn't work
I fortunately especially in
my later scripts have always
really worked the outline so that I feel
like it's pretty it it's it's pretty solid
but I would say that again going back to what I
referenced earlier if you feel that you've done
the outline you've done the due diligence on that
and you've done the script and it's not working
I would say go back and re-examine I think
you have to ask yourself why is this failing
like where where is it landing flat why is
it not because there's a lot of different
areas where you could be coming up short I'm sure
but I think it's it's fair to ask yourself okay
where is this coming up short going you may not
have to throw it all out but going back to the
outline and seeing okay maybe re-examining the
outline and then taking it and and reworking
the script again based on that new outline
or again it just may be one of those things where
the story just isn't materializing and you again
just maybe need to put that away for now and move
on to into another idea another story but again
my my advice would be really again to really with
the outline to really work it well to get your to
have your your your your key beats down and to
get feedback I think it's really important to
also get feedback from other writers and not and
people who give you a fair will give you a fair
fair hearing I don't I don't think you should
why I don't think you should be going to your
mom to get hurt because your mom and or your
dad or aunt sue and uncle johnny are gonna
love it no matter what they're they're
there to champion you and root you on
I also don't think it's great to go to somebody
who you may know is you want you who's especially
or unduly harsh I feel like you want people who
can be fair and with their constructive criticism
and say okay this is good this is good but this
doesn't work I think just I knew a few people in
college and again we were just starting out who
would just rip rip his or her fellow students
apart it was just I was like what's wrong with you
we're so I think you have to you have to encourage
that you always have to give encouragement
but I think you could do it in a fair
and critical way but I don't think you have to
rip the person apart personally so I think it's
finding that good balance and finding a good group
of people whom you trust who will give you fair
and critical feedback and from there I think
then it's about determining the direction you
want to go in do you go back and rework it or
do you just say what I'm going to shell this for
now and move on and I've known plenty of people
who have done both and again it's yeah so look
I I've started outlines and I've got an amount of
people and I haven't written a word and this this
happened in the last few years I wrote a number
of outlines and I gave them to people who I was
I value their opinion and they said what this
character just isn't likable or this plot just
isn't this this just isn't working mostly had
to do with the character these characters are
just highly unlikable and I don't see you really
making it making this as a film that that anyone's
really gonna get again have any empathy for anyone
that this this was one this is I'm just this was
one script in mind that that comes to mind and
another outline where it was just like yeah but
it's just certain elements just seem to be
too much of a stretch so I know for me it's
like if that outline isn't working and I'm getting
feedback and it's not coming in and there they're
people who I trust who are really giving me I
feel their a fair assessment and I was like okay
well I think I maybe it's just better I move
on and maybe later on I'll come back to this or
but this just doesn't seem to be hitting the the
notes that I wanted to you talked earlier about
blake schneider's save the cat yeah and you take
a lot from his outlining advice yeah he had and I
said I said earlier 16 beats it's 15 beats he has
the the main the main the 15 beats in his story
and they they they they pretty much fall in order
and take you through the story but they definitely
are I think a great guide and goal posts to
telling your story and doing an effective way and
they really hit on again and it goes back to I've
said it a few times working smarter not harder
being able to once you have a clear
log line and you're okay this is the
story I want to tell it's it's concise
and it's just it's 30 to 30 to 40 words
then you start you want to start
breaking it apart and I feel like
it starts with a character and from there you
basically fill in that character's journey from
the the first part I know it's always great as he
has opening image and the opening image is what's
the first thing we say what's the first thing to
remember and I think that's such a great exercise
it's like how do you want to open the story
what do you want the first thing people see
about your see about your character and what's it
what kind of impact is it going to have on them
when it goes all the way through telling it
talking about theme what's the inciting incident
the turn the first act turn the midpoint I will
say that I feel like and he did mention this is
in in his book is that the midpoint is really the
backbone of the story as he said I believe it's
what you hang everything on because the midpoint
basically is is that center point of the story and
it does the reversal really of where that story is
gonna turn and go often a lot of that the reversal
of the carrot for the character really it's such
an imperative beat in the character's journey
our hero's journey and then it goes through
the third act turn what's the climax and then
finally what's the last image we see if you think
about it and you really apply that and you again
reference any number of script but I reference the
movies you really get a good sense of seeing again
we talked about saving private ryan the film
version you see the elderly man at the end at
the beginning and then at the end and they like
to have those bookends a lot of writers like to
have the the bookends I sometimes have bookends
and it's I think it's it's great to tie it when
one and then the other I know one film that
I loved most recently that I've seen in years
or one of the films I love most recently was
1917 and it began and ended the same way and
it was obviously just breathtaking a breathtaking
journey that we went on and but yeah they again
identifying those beats and having your
character adhere to it and it doesn't have
to be so rigid I mean again they're guide posts
and their goal posts and everyone's is different
but I know for me that when I do set out it helps
me really determine where my character needs to
go in the story do you believe anyone can learn to
write a screenplay that will sell well there are a
ton of factors that go into that a lot of your
viewers have probably heard over the years that
you don't write what is fashionable at the moment
because then after you finished writing a script
you could spend six months a year
on it the market's already moved on
so I think again it goes back to you
can write a script about anything and
the most important thing is that your readers and
you care about the character or characters you're
writing about because if you're just writing it
to the mark and you're just running it to make
for a big spec sale which really don't happen that
man that much anymore they've kind of gone away
the marketplace has completely changed
it's it's one of those things where
I think you again have to write the story that
you feel compelled to and again if you're not
caring about your characters you the writer
or not your readers and your audience or not
it's a I mean it's a tricky question I
think anyone can write a script that sells
those factors and then you have to
have somebody a producer and actor
who are gonna really believe in it the the the
business has changed so much that now it seems
especially if you're not going the studio route
you have to get attachments you have to have
actors attached or a director and then the actor
comes in and then you'll attract financing for
it and and financing it all various levels there
have been many terrific screenwriters in in recent
years I've heard about who have written tremendous
spec scripts terrific specs that haven't sold
again because the business has changed so
much what you're seeing you know you can just
anyone can go and see what's at the cinema or
what's not at the cinema right now but what had
been pre-coveted it's it's sequels prequels comic
books adaptations there's really not a whole lot
of original material maybe some horror and comedy
films that are getting through but there just
really isn't there's a there's a darth of creative
material that's not happening and I I would just
say that you have to write what is true to you
I also would say that don't don't write about
yourself that old adage don't write about yourself
just try to write a compelling story tell a story
not your story which I think and again I've
known many writers starting out who wanted to
tell their life story and with all respect unless
you're some you've got some really incredible
rich just messed up and there are many who do but
stick to writing about what not about yourself per
se I think and you just never know who's going to
be interested anything can happen you you may you
still may send it into an agency or for looking
for representation they love it and they go out
with it you could send it to a producer you could
have that actor friend who knows this well-known
actor established actress and they get it in their
hands and they love it and they want to do it
I have a friend right now who called up an old
connection who's a well-known tv actor and he
he loved her script and he wants to do it he's
he's in but then it's a matter of getting other
actors attached and getting actors who are going
to get whoever they're going to bring in and and
be of value especially if you're going to
pre-sell the script in the in the states
overseas wherever so there's so many factors that
go into it now but I think then it just it does
always boil down to the fact of and comes back to
writing a compelling script but you're just never
gonna go to know where it's going to take you or
or how people are going to react let's take that
same student who came to you and said zach I want
to know how to write a script that's going to sell
how would you talk to them about working the
craft of writing how would you guide them I
would I would to speak to them about the asking
them again what is it what's the what's the idea
what's the what's the pitch what's the what how
are you going to sell this to me because again
screenwriting is selling you're not only
you're you're not only representing the
product the product that you're writing but
you're representing yourself in a lot of ways
especially when you get out there and
you start pitching or you go on meetings
the the the craft I mean again I would suggest
that they do read books like I mean go to
red sid field read blake snyder's books read
william goldman's books just try to get every
screenwriting book you can and then
read scripts read 10 20 scripts
before you actually sit down to start writing just
getting a sense of of how to go about it and how
again read read 10 oscar-winning screenplays
pretty tarantino read alan ball read read
brian helgeland
robert towne francis port coppola I would say
just read like all great scripts herman mankowitz
I guess herman right who's the it was who
wrote a citizen kane I know there were a few
makeovers I think it was herman yeah that new
david fincher movies out with about him but um
build get those again it goes back to
reference get use those as your reference
then I think I would say look you have an idea
what's your idea and what's your log line and
what is that what is it about that log line
that's fresh what is it about that log line that's
captivating what what's the twist what's the
irony and that's in that log line and then from
there just sort of repeating what I said about
earlier about then taking it the next steps
plotting exploring your character wanting
to know where they begin where they end
that's important what is that where does your
character start is he loathed is he loved by
the end is he loved or is he alot boiling
it down what's his journey what is he where
where's where are you taking us what do you want
to say with that what's your theme most important
that's a huge part is what are you trying to say
with us with your with your writing thematically
is it about the evils of of is it the evils
of war maybe that the best there are a lot
is it about a guy choosing
between love and money um
how far will you go for a corporation absolutely
absolutely what where where's or again somebody a
woman now or would she go for her for her children
to just watch the undoing on hbo with nicole
kidman and not to give anything away but that
goes that definitely touches on that theme and
not not to the person that you love not
being really who they they claim to be or
they are you thought they were unraveling
them or having the mystery behind someone
so I think that is something when you set
out to write like what are you trying to say
I had a friend of a friend boiled it down to
this when you're writing a story what's the
story about logogline what's it also about
what's it really about and those are those
are definitely I think when you set out like
those are questions that if you answer them and
those are the ones that take time but I think once
you answer them and you're you're you're truthful
about what it is and you're and this is where you
where you see it going again it's like
answering these tough questions early on
opens up the story for you and it's it's but
that's what I'm talking again about working
smarter not harder you can answer again those
those 15 beats and these additional questions
early on it's going to make your plotting process
and your and your writing far easier and and more
more enjoyable and you won't be banging your
head against the law or worse I like that so
what's it about what's it also about what's
it really what's it really about wow yeah
and that is yeah I remember hearing that probably
about 15 years ago and it definitely helped me
as a young writer I definitely like opened it up
like oh okay it's I think it's what it's basically
saying is once you have the log line that's
great but what is it you're trying to say but
dude what are you really what are
you really trying to do with this
and I think that's something that you
that people should be asked and sometimes
I think oftentimes people don't know they don't
they can't answer it it's like all right well
that's okay but you better well know it before
you sit down and you you take on the task of of
writing a 90 100 110 page script and devoting
your emotion and your time and taking away time
from other things to really devote to this
because it is your baby it is your child
you want to know your child inside out right
do the work do the do the do the smart work
I used to work at a company that had that banner
up above accounting I know and it said work and
I would sometimes transpo I would maybe that
was my own work hard or not smart oh no wait no
that's wrong and I like switch it yeah yeah it
is it's it's true it's and again I for me it's
something that came with with with age and
and becoming again maturity for sure and I
think initially we're we're impatient and look I'm
still impatient but with certain things I become
less much more patient in letting a process
play out it's not always easy but in the end
it's it's it definitely lends itself to more
I think more success and more productivity
if someone came to you and said I
want to learn how to write a script
that will sell yes what would you tell them well
I would tell them ask them what their log line is
and then I would really tell them to focus on
where that where that where they plan on taking
that character again I it's it's tough for me
everyone has their own tastes and everyone sees
things in a different in their own way I've it's
funny like I've put back in the day I submitted
scripts to contests and they do wonderfully in one
contest and make it to the finals or semi-finals
and then I'd submit that same script to another
contest or to a producer and they'd be like you'd
never hear from them or it wouldn't go anywhere
it is it is just it is so dependent on the taste
of the person you're sending it to I don't think
there's any formula I would say what
does help and is helping nowadays
is if writers have source material ip
intellectual property they have the rights to
a comic book in our newspaper
article as we were talking about
a novella a podcast podcasts
are being made if you own the ip
so many studios now are and production companies
etc are basing so much of them as we talked about
basing so much of the material on stuff that
on intellectual property that's already been
written or or produced or or spoken about
in the case of audio in the case of podcasts
so that is one way to go if it because then I
think if you've got a really compelling story
and you own the rights to it that definitely can
get a lot of people's attention you can say well
I want to write the script I don't know how most
people I don't know how again I guess it varies
from producer to studio head to what but that is
definitely a way to help break in again if it's
if it's a story of something really compelling or
multiple people are after it and you happen to own
the rights that's a nice negotiating bargaining
chip that you have a new a good way to negotiate
yourself in as a writer so yeah that's that's one
way to go I don't again there's no there's no sure
fire way to to come up I think again if you have
a really great if you're just writing it as a spec
if you've got a great log line and you have an
intriguing path forward for your character and
you send it to a few people who are like yeah
you're really onto something here then by all
means see it through but as we know there are
no guarantees in the business unfortunately
or should the question to the person be first off
before you want to write one that sells to ask
why you want to write I mean it's not like you're
selling time shares and hey show me how to do it
right and yeah what's the hot market I mean right
and it goes back it goes back to what you write
what you think are I guess you want to write right
now the western has come back and they let's just
say and it's it's a it's a hot market I mean for
a while there it was after gravity right they were
they were doing all these everyone wanted the
studios and producers of all varieties wanted
a great space film it's like okay so I'm sure
there were a lot of people who saw gravity got
inspired by our becoming writers and were like
yeah I'm going to write that next great space
film and it very well may have been a great
space film but guess what the market's moved on
and it's like again I think you have
to just you can't write for the market
in a way you have to let the market come
to you and that means writing a story that
it goes back to writing a story with compelling
characters who you actually give a poop about
and want to see want them and you
have others who are invested in them
or in their journey it's that's what I would say
and and you you may you ask a question like well
why why are you writing what's the point are
you in this to make a buck are you in this too
do you actually really enjoy the craft and the
process and all that and you really have to
I'm sure there's some writers who have just
set out to write a script and they've done
it and they've made money and but I think the
majority of us we really have to be inspired by
the type of story we want to invest six
months a year if you're writing a novel
two three four five years into sure so drive
did well but if then you're trying to copy
that style or yeah you always have to be and I
think you always kind of have to be reinventing
yourself I don't say reinventing
yourself as a writer but
in a way yes because you you always have to come
at it I think from a different angle an original
angle look again coming back to the space story
you know the market may move on but maybe if you
have a unique twist on you know that space
story or on a werewolf story or whatever I
think it's always having that always looking
at in a way you could have how do I say it
you can have a same approach to crafting
it but you have to have a fresh take on
constantly a fresh take on on different stories
and how you want to not necessarily want to tell
them but you know fresh takes and twists on on on
your material and and what you're trying to say
and I referenced 1917 it was like not only
was that technically well done in my opinion
I just thought that from a sheer filmmaking
standpoint but more importantly from a character
standpoint I mean we were in the we've got to
get we're with this guy trying to get and it's
really not a complicated story he's trying to get
to get across france to this guy to tell him that
these men are going to die and it's life or
death and his friend dies along the way and
man we are invested these two guys these two
young guys in the middle of this brutal war
oh my god I am similar saving private orion I
mean you don't have to be a lover of war films
to just be like I was on the edge of my seat
and it was just and sam mendez is just such a
wonderful director but wow and again not a
an overly complicated story but just just
being invested entirely in the characters
and then getting there in the end and
it's like he delivers he saves the men and he has
to then then he's got to deliver this news to the
to the lieutenant whose brother he was with who
died oh man I mean I was I had tears streaming
down my eye my my cheeks it was just it was it was
but it was it just you talk about a film that just
worked all that stew just worked brilliantly I
like that that's good oh man it was wonderful
a stew yeah that's good creative stew yeah but
for me personally I hadn't experienced that
in for in a film in a while and I guess I used
to more but I think it shows where sort of the
where movie making has gone studio filmmaking
has gone to an extent what's the best part
of the writing process for you that is a
profoundly good question I think when you
find that synergy between your characters in
the plot and again things are starting to roll
and and it could be in the outline phase too
I've had plenty of experiences with having that
breakthrough where you're like oh right this is
this is where I need to go it's not I don't
think it's necessarily one thing it could be
you write it you write a terrific scene or
a great chapter and you're just like yeah
then of course you could always go back the
next day and think what the hell did I write
but that doesn't happen as much I think when you
feel when you feel like you really pulled out and
you really expressed yourself in a way that or had
the characters express themselves in a way that
resonates with you I again I think I think it it's
it can be any it's it can be anything again from
really thinking up a cool plot point to really
getting that lock that log line down we were like
oh this is I'm on with this and I'm one of those
people who's I know william broyles jr who is
a terrific screen right he's one of the best he
always I remember reading an interview with him
years ago saying never be satisfied and I agree
I'm not always satisfied I always want to um
i always think I can do things better I'm a
perfectionist I always want to continue to mine
and if somebody says to me this we can do that I'm
like great let's let's do it let's mine this let's
let's keep let's dig so so for me I think when
the the the the the time where I really feel where
I love with the process that I love is I think
it's just it's the discovery discovery of again
your character where they're going and it could
be the character is in is in trouble and how do
we get him or her out of it what's a creative way
of doing it and always thinking again I hate the
expression outside the box but thinking outside
the box coming with a new way and a new twist and
and how that being inventive and when that works
and it's working on the page and you or you think
it's working on the page and you're like oh that's
cool and it opens up and it's that it's those
those psychological breakthroughs in a
sense in in regard to the creative process
so when you start to see that wow these dots are
connecting this is actually working it's great
it's great it really is it's yeah it gives you
it gives you confidence and you you just feel it
it's it buoys your spirit a little bit like I said
the next day you could go back and you're like
okay I got through this now that's why I get it's
good to have an outline but even in having the
outline and knowing how do you start up especially
in writing writing that next scene or writing the
next chapter you're still staring at a blank page
you have an idea of where you want to go but then
it's a matter of really inventing that and it's
that's something else that's exhilarating but also
daunting at the same time without a doubt what's
the fastest you've ever written a full screenplay
and did that screenplay get made fastest I
actually I wrote take back pretty quickly
the first draft was probably a couple of
weeks after it outlined it it was pretty quick
it took a little while to get made and it went
through subsequent through a number of drafts but
yeah I probably wrote in about three weeks three
to four weeks maybe no not even four weeks I think
it was like three weeks three weeks yeah I had it
I had it pretty much locked in but again that was
the first draft and that's the other thing it's
writing is rewriting is rewriting is rewriting so
what I always enjoy actually and
I should back this up is that
putting the script down is that putting that
primer down is is fun but I really enjoy going
back and going back into it and reworking it and
reworking it and reworking it because I think if
you've laid down a good blueprint and you have a
good bare bones what you're basically transferring
from the outline to that to that script I
think that going back and reworking it and
making and polishing it and and really exploring
it even more that's when the real work is done
and that I think is what's most rewarding for
me personally is the rewriting process for sure
have you ever fallen in love with a character
not one that you'd written but another one where
you felt that the person was real
we were talking about earlier about
salinger and the letters and this book that I
read and these people related so much to holden
caulfield and they just right they felt he was so
real sure did you ever feel that for a character
whether a book I don't say falling in love
but I I've had some characters that I've
been really taken by santiago and the old man
in the sea nelson demille who's a contemporary
mystery detective write novels he's sold very
well he wrote the general's daughter and a few
other that have been made into movies
he has a character a plum island john
corey's character who I adore I think he's
and demille's always like his written some
some he's john corey is wonderfully entertaining
and funny and witty and and acerbic and
and empathetic and I love I love his cat I
love that character off the top of my head um
i really recently I'm like a lot of
other people read where the crawdads sing
and the the young little girl who grew up and
just just sheer empathy for her and her story
again I don't I didn't fall in love but just
loved where what happened and where she went
where they took where the writer took her
and and just being so involved and rooting
for her so fiercely I could say that
about jay gatsby is so mysterious and
and I was always fascinated more by jay gatsby
and I like I loved catcher in the rye but there
was always something just that allure about jay
gatsby and yeah and again I've again my memories
coming up short but yeah I don't know I've been
invested heavily I don't know that I've ever
completely fell in love with with a character but
heavily invested in rooting for yeah and adoring
characters for sure and I know I gave you novels
I didn't give you necessarily screenplays but
I think one of the one of the reasons that I
am that I am still french connection is one of
my favorite films is the dynamic between gene
hackman and roy scheider popeye doyle and sunny
I forgot his last name it was cloudy was the
nickname popeye and cloudy obviously was their
buddy dynamic but also it was again
I these were new yorkers like myself
and they had that attitude and they they really
I just always took a shine to them I thought they
were they were terrific and and really loved
them and loved how loved their dynamic and
and the movie in general did you like serpaco
yeah another great one pacino again New York
yeah New York and and his his intensity
in that for sure and in a lot of his films
how do you write an emotional scene I have a I
have a 17 year old and we had a her we were it's a
that's an interesting story in itself that I won't
get too into but she's we didn't her mom and I
didn't didn't go about having her the traditional
way it was she was a wonderful surprise
and
i think after especially as she got older I
we've always been very close we still are and
she's my heartbeat and I think as a father
it definitely feeds into again it's like as a
writer your stories are your your babies your
children and you feel for them you care for
them and you really and I think I think there
was something about becoming a dad especially at a
young age which I was I was 26 when I became a dad
that really helps you
understand and empathize with characters
and and tell a story that's compelling I
again I always am able to I feel like take a
take a step back and really delve into that
and we've all dealt we've all dealt with loss
I mean I lost my father at a fairly young age
older than a lot of people but still pretty young
and he he was a a a seminal figure in my life
and I feel like the again like the relationship
that I had with him and with my daughter and
again having experienced
great loss great great love
it definitely I think having those relationships
helps on a lot of levels especially when you're
writing an emotional scene whatever it
may be it was definitely with take back
the fear of something like that happened to my
daughter and drove it at the time she was when
I first started writing it she was eight and
almost nine and I read about girls as young as
her age throughout the world even the united
states of being taken as or being sold off and
especially she got older and we got further
along in the development of the script and
then I became made it was definitely like oh
my god she's this could happen to her and it
so there's definitely some fear that that drove
it for sure and I know and it's like how do you
as also sort of like how do you come back
from that how do you rebuild your life
those were those are definitely questions that
I experienced throughout and as a father it
definitely had a had a huge impact I think we
can always relate back to our to our personal
experiences and pull from that I think you have to
and not everyone unfortunately and unfortunately a
lot of writers didn't have that type of tragedy or
anything that happened to him and I certainly I've
my dad didn't die in a terribly tragic way
but you still feel the same emotion if you
lose somebody you're close to and if you
can infuse that in your writing and use that
you definitely again it goes back to us
really caring and giving a crap about
your characters and your story do you miss
your characters when you're done writing
yeah sometimes I think if that's a great question
I think if you get really invested in that story
there's something about it too because I've gone
back to rewrite scripts for people over the years
that I had written and they wanted to see a draft
or I've been they've been development for a while
and I'll put them aside and go do something else
because that draft is where it is at the moment
but I always look forward to going back and
reworking it it's always good to see old friends
again seeing and I've certainly gone back I'm like
ugh I'll cringe what did I write what did I do
but yeah now I there's definitely something
when you're done with a script and you're
you you put it aside or you're
done in that moment there's
you've kind of got to let it go it gets easier as
you re as you write more and you can breathe and
I've never been one of those people who's so
wrapped up in his world and and the characters and
that worked for some and I don't wanna but I've
never I've been able to I don't know it sound bad
some people live and they're in their characters
worlds and that's wonderful I didn't mean to
dilute that experience for them or or anything
but for me it's like I've I'm invested when I'm
writing and then I'm I am at the end of the day
able to pull myself away of course I think about
story and where when I'm not there but I think
once I'm done and yeah if you've spent a long
time on them and you're done you do miss it
a little bit you miss that story a little bit
but then again you always kevin your back of
your head well I may need to go back in to
again make it better refine it so I'll be back
I'll see you in a little while take some time
have a beer and a cigarette and I'll
get you on down the line and so yeah
Zach you've been generous to send us your script
for take back my pleasure so we'd love to do
a page one analysis sure so for page one
of take back can you talk about the world
you were trying to create yeah absolutely this was
basically again we go back to that opening image
and really wanting to get a grip a grasp of
what this film is about right off the bat
essentially hitting the audience of the head so
they know what kind of film this is going to be
and we're in a dark we're in a van we're not
sure where we're not sure with who but we can get
we we can guess pretty quickly that it's a young
woman and she's in a bag and she's tied up and
we're not sure what that is happening doors
are thrown open and she's held out by a bunch
of seedy looking guys and we hear voices and
we can pretty much grasp that she's been taken
she's been kidnapped and she's going to
be used to make these guys money somehow
and we can only guess our worst our
worst nightmare or her worst nightmare is
really what happens and that sort of sets up the
story and the data was essentially going back to
what is that opening image and now is that going
to set up the story what does it mean for genre
does it mean for character what is it that
we see right away and how are we going to get
everyone invested right off the bat how many
characters are introduced in this page one scene
well again and I don't want to give I don't want
to give too much away I won't give too much away
we do meet mickey rourke's character this will
be him who comes through and we do meet the well
I'll just leave it at that I will say who we it's
three it's three characters who we meet right from
the get-go from that opening page so you introduce
one of the characters as a vacant looking man
rather than the character name right and that
actually I can say that that winds up being
mickey rourke's the charac mickey
works character whose name is patrick
winds up being his doomed brother I personally
like to reveal as little up front as possible
making it keeping as much mystery involved
and keeping that reader turning the page
which are obviously tied together is
so in my in my process is so imperative
giving out just little bits and pieces here and
there again I know for some riders it seems like
it's par for the course that's the way it should
be but it's not always the easiest thing because
you don't want to reveal too much information
you want it to just slowly come in in drips
in drips and keep it going and it's it's not
always easy to do it's not always easy to do
but in this instance yes I wanted to just leave
when I say vacant looking man he'll be coming back
later as a vacant looking man but then eventually
we understand who he is and where he's identified
in the in the story so as you said earlier
moving the story forward but again with
drips you don't you just want to hint at this
absolutely keeping the pace and going I never
and again this is just me I am very fastidious
about this it's like scenes should be about two
pages when you're writing each scene should be
two pages so if you're writing they always say
60 60 scenes if you will times 220 pages
obviously the length of films have come down so
I always try to think about maybe 40
scenes and conflict within those 40
those 40 scenes I should say earlier within
the blake snyder thing there are the 15 beats
that he then expands to 40 beats within a story
so for me it's and I think you could be anywhere
between 30 and 40. but you figured those 40
beats are usually between two and three pages
roughly is what you're aiming for so so yeah it
and again I apologize for not expanding upon that
earlier but just initially getting a sense of the
main beats for the character then expanding those
and that takes you through the rest of the story
for the most part for me keeping scenes between
two to three pages and keeping action lines
never clumping them really keeping it sparse
letting the story flow letting the script and
screenwriting is very different than prose
writing screen lighting is very it's punchier you
don't want to write a lot of surprise description
you want to keep it short you want to keep it
compact you want to get to the point right away
and that also has that also ties
into the pacing of of your story
at least it does for me and I and
that that is that's part of the flow
so again keeping keeping it keeping it tight
keeping it punchy lots of white page and just
letting it letting it flow letting it flow a fluid
fluid script you don't want to get too clumped up
and you want to keep the pages turning
so action line van rolls to a stop
next line side door is thrown open right blinding
light floods in yeah right just and there there
is like a rhythm exactly there's always a rhythm
shadow shrouded faces appear rough uncompromising
hands grab pull and drag us out I can I can see
it I can feel like I'm there right yeah and and
you want and and again this is this is not it it's
you may get you may have to go through seven eight
nine drafts before you get that rhythm down that's
why rewriting is so important first draft you get
it down great good for you there's going to be
a lot more there's going to be subsequent drafts
where you're really trying to find that pacing
finding that rhythm finding that that flow to it
that's all part of the process and it's certainly
for me and that's what that's what took me again
I've I wrote many drafts for this script until
I really got to that point where I'm like okay
it flowed it flowed how many drafts
over the years easily 25 30 it was a lot in all
various stages not complete page one rewrites but
definitely different versions writing different
rewriting different scenes can you tell us
about the smash cut I it's funny because I don't
usually don't like putting in I try to avoid stage
directions as much as possible or cuts cut twos
I'm very limited with those if I'm doing it it has
it's it's there for to have a profound effect
on your match it's almost like a match cut from
your your character in one scene's punching
and then next scene that character is punching
or another character's punching so it's sort of
like that smash cut it's it's a quick cut to sort
of match to to gel the two scenes together in a
very fast way normally I don't like putting in
again stage directions or those inserts can you
tell us about the smash cut though literally
it seems like was it a happy accident or or
deliberate it was on the bottom yeah that that
very well may have I think it was that was the end
of the scene and I think it was it was probably
more of a happy accent than anything else but it
was great because it ended on that first page so
hopefully they're reading to the second page when
they see that how long did it take you to write
this first page well it was again it was it was
rewritten but something like that again I mean I
it was I don't have a I don't
have a time frame for that but
there are times where I've been able to write
a page like that within a couple of minutes
other times it takes longer because again
I'm refining it and I'm finding my way
but it it can vary a whole a whole
lot of different length of time for
that particular process and when you said you did
roughly 25 rewrites I realized they weren't all
page one rewrites but what part in particular
did you work most at that needed the most part
oh most mostly her journey changing it for because
funny enough mickey rourke's character was a woman
really but we got mickey and I was like they
said can you make this a man I said sure
why not mickey rourke why not sure that definitely
changed that dynamic a little bit but I think it
had more to do with her journey and her character
and then at other times making the plot making it
fresher updating it I would say at certain points
some of the action I think for the most part
it's zara now but in the script it's sarah
the zara character or sarah sorry I did
change her along the way and there was definitely
certain changes but she always was kind of like
again I I stuck it was this woman who committed
this act of heroism she was trying to escape her
past had the spotlight turned back on her and
all the all the bugs came out under the light to
make her life a living hell and she had to fight
back and take her life back so that was kind of
always that was pretty much always there so
but there were always tweaks that I made too
again her story and her background
and just to make it more compelling
and her more compelling is this first page
still the opening of the movie I don't know
I don't I don't think it is okay judging from the
trailer too I'm not sure I don't think it is okay
yeah well I don't want to say anything sadly okay
jeopardize it because I really like that opening
but again can't be wedded to our
work yeah you get paid and it's like
looking back at it now with the first page
take back were there any mistakes anything
you feel like you could have done better
or you happy with exactly how it flows
I do like the flow I am I'm never gonna say
I'm satisfied but I'm happy with where it's at
at the moment somebody came around and
said hey we could do this I'd be like great
I like that idea let's do it amenable to it I
think filmmaking is so much about collaboration
and hearing other people out kind of like
a life which we've kind of eschewed lately
I feel that you should always be willing to hear
what people have to say even if you don't like the
idea hear them out don't dismiss it outright
if it's the most inane effing idea you okay
but somebody may just as an aside say yeah but you
might think about giving her a little charm blaze
that you can bring back later or something like
that as a symbol bad example but think about it
that's a really good idea work that in or some way
symbolize that symbol term ties back to the theme
so where it's at now I think it accomplishes
what it needs to I think it sets up the
sets up the film with some mystery we
get a sense of danger we get a sense
of establishing what genre does
we get a nice opening image um
yeah but and I will backtrack that getting to that
opening image the actual writing of it didn't take
long but I think working around some scenes that
had been there prior and making it that took some
re-shifting and some rewriting the actual scene
itself to write wasn't too didn't take too long
but there was definitely parts of drafts that
were different that had different opening images
and I think for me it was about streamlining it
and making it as concise and simple and quick
as possible again that's how I work I want to know
delving into it as quickly as possible and getting
to the story and getting to our our characters
and and and getting to those those main beats as
fast and concisely as possible is so important did
you cut down a lot of dialogue and of the action
lines it's not too much there were some there were
some yeah probably maybe in that instance maybe a
quarter a half a page yeah because they didn't
really need to be much that needed to be said
that's what I that was in my intention again
I think you do more by showing more and saying
less take back coming out in 2020 2021 I'm
I don't quote me it should be coming out in
between april and june we're hoping it's some I'd
just say the spring at some point in the spring
maybe mid to late spring right and it was shot
during covid it was shot during kovid it was one
of the few movies made during covet it was shot
in la and out in the palm springs area yes right
and it stars stars mickey rourke michael jai white
gillian white james russo and a handful of other
actors and actresses who you've definitely seen
at a theater near you or on television so yeah
yeah it was a really good cast really they did
a terrific job with the casting without a doubt
and I know it it took a little bit to get made
and were yeah it was it was it was definitely
a process we had a again I had met through I had
sent the script to a producer friend of mine and
he had gotten it to the christian sesma who's
the director and my captain who's a producer
both have worked extensively in the business mike
is actually as an actor he was in the green book
and number of other films christians worked on a
number he christian actually has just had a film
come out early this year with val kilmer called
paydirt and he's directed a number of other films
and yeah so we went to them and
they they signed on pretty quickly
and then we were able to get mickey work attached
and we unfortunately had an investor drop
out and we needed to fill that so we went to
a financier fairly big finance here in town
who stepped in and we unfortunately
weren't able to get it done with him
so we we signed on and then it just it just
didn't happen and then we the rights reverted
back to me and after that we were able to find
a financier pretty quickly plug the the budget
shortfall that we had had from the initial
investor backing out and we got it made and
it's it'll be out soon excellent okay and we'll
have a trailer of course in the link below yeah
absolutely that is the official trailer now we're
gonna go to page two and we see our protagonist
and she's sparring and she's throwing a punch why
did you decide this was the best way to introduce
the protagonist sure well I wanted to have a part
of the put an impact on how we see her right away
the next the next scene is of her as an attorney
she's a small town attorney I wanted to set up
the fact that she had a bond her husband is
the one she's sparring with in the scene we
don't know until the end of the scene that it's
him we think she's just doing a sparring session
with someone but it's her husband who's taught
her all this she's proficient she's athletic and
she's an accomplished lawyer in this small town
for me those were the priorities set her up as
well as a relationship with her husband and we
did it without a lot of dialogue more of the
action I also wanted to establishers martial arts
involved in the story and again this is going to
be a thriller with action elements so for me and I
think as a writer putting as much of that in there
without saying much I think is really important
I had mentioned earlier I think sometimes people
especially young writers start out and they
become just enamored of dialogue and the less
you can say to move your story forward the better
dialogue should be there to service the story
to move the plot forward to move your
character forward not just to you know
I think people just will throw an extraneous
dialogue just because they love the sound of
it and it does nothing for the story except
slow the pacing as we've been alluding to
and for me and that in those scenes it
was like just get to the point without
saying a whole lot in expressing it in
images because movies are images and I
once a professor of mine actually at NYU said
if you can watch a whole film with a sound off
and at the end understand then that movie's
been successful you don't have to listen to
what they're saying and you just follow the images
that's pretty darn good if you can say it without
tarantino film might be difficult to watch that
way but at the same time you you'd be surprised
even though he is such a master dialogue writer
and he's so terrific with that he can still
put together a heck of a story on pages eight
through 11 we have our next piece of action which
serves as the inciting incident I believe okay
can you talk about the moment in the screenplay
whether it was structured or not yeah that was
definitely structured because that's where she
goes in and has that becomes the hero and
exposes herself so that was definitely always
going to be the inciting incident for sure
is it okay to talk about what happens here
yeah there's not too many spoilers okay not at
all so she's she's it shows too that that her her
strength training and and martial arts
and and the boxing and all that becomes
a major piece in this it comes in handy yes
big time and she again she commits that act
of heroism that then exposes her to the
national media and she becomes a story
right and then you see that her phone she starts
being text by family journalists all these
different things exactly and what seems like sort
of an exciting good thing is quickly about to turn
yes exactly again she's exposed she's
exposed to the wrong people as it were yeah
seems like there's a lot more dialogue in this
section yeah okay yeah it was it was basically
she's trying to talk this guy down and and say
look you know speaking to the speaking to the
checkout counter girl but and then ultimately him
wanting that pin that was so important to her and
that her husband had given her which is symbolic
which is a symbol throughout the rest of the film
that definitely drove most of the dialogue
there and became the source of conflict for her
taking the guy down because he wanted that
pin and she wasn't going to give it up
and she was able to take him out I think if she
had just said I don't want any trouble just walk
she would have let him walked but
because he decided to instigate
she had the wherewithal and the training to to
do that and put him out in a very heroic way
so yeah and the pin sorry that's not a mcguffin is
it no it's okay so I was thinking of a macguffin
it would be some type of a symbol or so correct
me how would that be what would what would that
be called that pin because it interplays into
the right I would just say it's symbolic of the
relationship and the dynamic that she's created
with her with her husband because it's symbol
is an Asian symbol for best friend okay and it's
and he gave it to her and it's emblematic of their
relationship and their it comes to play as the
story goes on that she still has it and in the end
when again not to give too much away but when
you do have that she does have that final battle
it's and again this is in the script that it's
something that she has to she gained strength from
in the knowledge that again she's wearing
this on her heart and it's again emblematic
of her husband's support and her life her new
life and how the old one is coming back and
that contrast and she has
to be strong and stay strong
and hold on to the new life and not let the
old obviously nightmarish one come back for her
and not only that but this stranger who has held
up the liquor store the convenience store he wants
that yes and that's he wants to take it from a
symbol too of yeah exactly right right exactly
yes so in many ways it's symbolic of this is her
new life and then an evil force is trying to come
and take it absolutely interesting in a place
throughout it plays throughout and again it was
it's definitely one of those things where there
there are there are a lot of people that force
that force-feed symbols in sometimes in movies but
I think it can definitely be done in a way that's
subtle and still have greater meaning and to
the rest of the story throughout and carry it
throughout are they dramatically okay and are
there overt symbols and then covert symbols
like I think they said with like the artist they
they showed like a descending stairs when it was
the economy was bad sure and that some viewers
I mean I actually wasn't totally aware of that
yeah I think some of those are choices
by the director I think sometimes
in a script we do we will put stuff in a symbol in
of of some kind we hope to make something tangible
but oftentimes I think the choices
that directors make or on their set
when they're making the movie it becomes they they
kind of come up with their own they find a way
to to play it up whatever it may be sometimes it's
in the script but other times yeah I think they
the way it's shot and the way the set's designed
as we said in film school the mison sen sort of
lends itself to creating those opportunities for
some for symbolism in a film how many drafts of
the script did you do before you had other people
start reading it at that point maybe a dozen
i was yeah I was rewriting it a bit because
sometimes I would come back to it somebody
would be interested well I shouldn't say
initially my manager got it out to people so
I mean early I would say maybe not that many
when somebody the first person read it whatever
it was seven eight years ago so yeah and maybe
I shouldn't say that maybe it was maybe three
or four drafts I went back and rewrote it a couple
of times before I actually started sending it out
for sure and again it was a different time there
weren't the studios I think were still putting
those movies out and there were still producers
who were willing to put up and financiers who were
willing to put up their own money and they didn't
need necessarily need stars attached they would
work with you develop it with you and I think
became more prevalent in recent years where
they started attaching actors and and directors
and trying to pre-sell the film especially in the
independent world before they would before
they would commit to going into production
what were the first notes you were given on
the screenplay my manager early on I think
I don't recall what they were I think he liked
my first couple because I probably wrote a draft
and rewrote it and then got it to him overall I
think it was pretty positive this was sort of what
he had in mind but I don't remember exactly what
the detail I'd have to go back and look for that
email I'm sure I saved it but yeah it was it
was it was my my manager is a wonderful guy
still is he's one of my my dear became one
of my dear friends he was great because he
always saw a big picture he was never a micro
note giver he was more of a macro note giver
and sometimes he'd sent he gave me feedback
and I would be like what's he saying
and then it would hit me later that
day or the next day I'm like okay
because it would be vague but I'd think about it
and then it would be vague anymore he had that
gift and I've always been what I've given my
friends I'm a macro note giver I try to be as
concise as possible as positive as possible
I don't like to burden people with
too many notes I find big picture
I have big picture thoughts try to go for maybe
two or three again sometimes they're good they
might be very positive notes like keep doing this
sometimes okay you have to pick up the pacing
here but I don't I don't get into the minutiae
of note giving I'm pretty broad speaking and
it depends some people prefer that other
people don't I know sometimes for me
I would like people to be more specific because
it would help but everyone has their own way of
of giving notes so I just I just I just
roll with it as best as I can and try to
again try to be as helpful and inspiring as I
can with my notes to people and encouraging I
should say not inspiring but encouraging
can you give me an example of micro notes
yeah micro note giving is a bad
example why is his name bob and not jim
bad example I just I just feel like very
much in the minutia maybe starting to sort of
you know at times it's helpful but rewrite
dialogue in a way that I don't think is really
maybe the the prime problem in that script
where it's like okay we have a script
we don't care about the main character
at this point it's it's page 10.
they're they're being overly descriptive
they're they have a voice over that's basically
explaining everything that's going on
and and it's slow and the pacing is off
but we're talking about this one stretch of
dialogue or again maybe not the best example but
it's stuff like that where I feel like I'm always
like okay what do I really like about this script
always start off with that but then say okay but
I feel like you have a and I'll focus on certain
parts of the script like act three doesn't have a
hard enough turn where where have they where has
he where is he or she at the end of the story
or at the end of the second act when they have
to make that they have that cathartic moment that
then is going to turn them into the third act like
really what is that why they started
out here at the beginning of the script
they're now at their lowest ebb they're in the the
dark knight of their soul and their what is going
to bring them out of that they're at their lowest
point what is it that that's going to turn them
that's made it all up into this point that's
going to make them make that turn that hard turn
into the third act in order to finish their
story and and win in the win in the end it's
stuff like that which I think I again and I think
a lot of people focus on but I think sometimes
macro notes we start getting again into the
into the real minutia sometimes people like
that sometimes it helps but unless you're unless
you've gotten you've been paid to write and you're
and you're getting a thousand note a thousand
notes from the studio executive or producer with
every little line iteming every every part of it
it's it's I don't know I don't know how always how
helpful it is but yeah but that's just me how do
you protect your script before sending it out wga
register it copywriting isn't the worst
idea either but I think most most wga get
it registered the wga it's like 20 bucks you can
do it online it takes like five minutes if that
and your cover and I think it covers your
for for up to five years renew it after that
but yeah that's and copyrighting to a degree
but I think in the business as long as you
have a wga I know there there have been a lot
of instances of people having their work stolen
etc and and it's I should say a lot but there
are instances of it I think people are more
I don't know again I've heard of it happening
but I think it happens less than maybe
people think that stealing material
I you guys may have heard of
more so but I've always known that there
again there are some instances like I know the
coming to america script was like a big deal that
that somebody claimed that eddie murray murphy
stole that stole their idea and it was a whole
lawsuit dodgeball I believe was another one
so yeah um
again I would say to cover but to
cover yourself and your story yeah wga
or just wga west or east they have registration
you go in there and that definitely covers you
up too it gives you a little or gives you a lot
of comfort knowing that you're there that you're
have your script registered not mailing it to
yourself poor man's copyright that's a that's
a good question I mean potentially but you could
do that but I would also say and I think also with
having electronic documentation if you do send it
out can't hurt correspondent I don't know people
write many letters anymore but having physical
correspondence but I I think the wga is definitely
the the easiest and the smartest way to go are
you careful with who you share your ideas with
I am family members ask I will tell them friends
who I I've known for a while sometimes I'll
be out and will whenever I'm among people who
especially my I'm in the writers group I share
and I've shared it with some
other folks I don't get to
and I'm gonna I'm gonna knock wood here I don't
get to I don't get too worried about it again
because I know that I have my script registered
and and all that and I have a good lawyer
i have a really good lawyer so they can try
but he's a savage so and he's he's pretty well
known so you try I don't think it would be a good
idea in general what are the best ways to have an
uncredited writer find script buyers well there
are I know that the contests have always been a
way to get your work out there I think there are a
handful of of contests like the nichols fellowship
or nickel pickle fellowship a few other
contests that are there I would I think any
writers starting off you should go you can google
it best screenwriting contest and see for yourself
and that's one way to do it I mean the fees
the fees it's usually anywhere between early
entry fees or anywhere between 40 and 60 bucks
I don't think they've fluctuated much in in the
last 15 20 years that's one way to go I will say
with the contests you gotta win I think if you
win it opens doors I think even if you make it
in the finals I placed in a lot of contests in
in semifinals quarterfinals finalists even in
nickel right I was a semi-finalist in nickel
years back with the pirate hunter script believe
it or not which was a shock I just sort of
submitted it for poops and giggles and went in and
it made it and made it all the way to semifinals
I had that was actually a film a script that I
had co-written with an old friend of mine and
I was amazed because I know the nickel always
focused seemed to focus more on drama maybe
some comedy some thriller but this was a straight
straight action movie so I was impressed that it
it got as far as it did and it got me my
first manager who is still my dear friend
so it definitely opened some
doors it got me some meetings um
but I feel like you still need to come away
with the top prize in that maybe a runner-up
there's also for writers inc tip
which is a website that is devoted to
you put your logo you can upload your log line
synopsis you can put a treatment and a script
and or I think it's treatment and or a script up
there and that definitely there there are a lot of
production companies who are on there
there's I think they have something like 15
000 members and that you can subscribe they send
your log line out and you'll have people come and
they can contact you I used to have some stuff
listed on there I had somebody contact me
never really materialized but there
are people that are looking that's one
way to reach reach other folks other
than that I know it's time of covid
networking is definitely a good way to go it
really is all about who and that's that's that's
a great way and and working working in an agency
working in a in a production company those those
are definitely ways of you you can get your work
to somebody potentially within those agencies
companies etc that might be able to open some
doors for you working working on shows working on
a tv show working on a film and continuing to
work on various productions again you accrue a
lot of people they know it's what happened with me
when I started off knowing going from one to the
next to the next and sort of broadening your your
scope of contacts it's a funny story I remember
this is before I even thought about it being a
tv writer I was on I had just left law and order
the law and order show after two years and
I had given my script to a writer there
and she got in touch with me a couple months
later she said I read your script it's really good
she said have you considered tv writing and at
the time tv writing I just wanted to write movies
and foolishly and this is something that I
say to anyone watching if you have one of
the top tv writers on law order or one of the tv
writers in the business and again this was before
the advent of like tv was starting to come to the
fore and and you were starting to get into the
golden age but this was like probably a few years
before that and I was just so focused on being
film writer but this woman said to me and I given
her the script because I admired and respected her
immensely and her talent when she was one of
the top writers there I said she wrote she she
called me she said this is really good and have
you considered writing tv and I said I haven't
and she said well I would and I didn't
really heed that call until later and I
did write some pilots and I actually did get some
meetings with folks and tv and some at some of the
networks with some of the pilots I had written
but I wish I had heeded that call earlier and
some of your viewers are probably looking at this
and saying what a schmuck and you yours are right
what a schmuck if you have that opportunity you
you hear those voices you they're it's all signs
read the signposts if somebody says hey what you
may want to consider writing this or working on
that or take it because there are not a lot of
opportunities in the in the film business and
if you if you're there to heed the call it could
lead to some really potentially wonderful things
that's a great story yeah I mean maybe
just wasn't right for you at that time
I wouldn't I was young and dumb and etc that's
all I'll say I had certain things that yeah
if I think back but yeah she was a she was a
I mean for her for her because I was gone from
the from the the the the show at that time
I was long gone she did not have to call me
she did not have to call me up and you know when I
left I said to her like I always I told her I said
I really appreciated you really were inspiring to
work for you were always really cool and and and
and I admired who you were who you are so I don't
know if that did it but she did get back to me she
didn't have to and she did and she was just very
complimentary and I just wish in hindsight maybe I
had but like you said I was in a different place
than I think I was 25 yeah so and you're thick
at that and that's what I'm saying like it there
takes some maturation also do so many things are
being presented to you at that age and and so
I think there's this weird skew that you think
it's always going to be yes that way especially
you do and and you do you just think no I won't
I get that next opportunity in three months right
something else right and and you you look the one
thing I'll say is that nobody ever said to me
and I'll still knock wood nobody ever said to me
stop writing you just don't do it it's you need to
find a new career path nobody ever said that to me
and I mean I guess we wouldn't really say that
to anybody but if somebody's really being blunt
sometimes they would like you just don't
have it and I'm not saying I'm I have it
I'm just saying that in my professional
experience nobody ever said just stop
this isn't for you sure and sometimes if someone
says it doesn't even mean it's that somebody's
trying to sabotage someone so you just never know
what their opinion right what their agenda is
and a funny and real funny story so that
script that went to the semifinals in nickel
three months earlier we had somebody submitted to
this film production company which is no longer
around and they made a couple of comedies
that weren't very good but their director of
development it's though it is the meanest response
I ever received and I was my writing partner and I
at the time we received it this development
exec said it's not such-and-such material
it's not this company's material I remember
thinking and you made that film and you're
and I was I was so one we went and
I'll tell you I admire my restraint
because after we made it all the
way to the semifinals it was like
I still had a little bit of acid in my mouth about
that I just want to write oh really well it's
nickel material but I didn't do that I'm not like
that I just but I was like wow that was definitely
just I don't know if she meant this isn't for
us but to just to go out of their way and say
this is not this doesn't rise to our level
I was like wow okay yeah you just wanted to
put you just wanted to put us down all right
all right well they're non-existent anymore so
we all got the last laugh because
somebody went to see their movies I guess
but it was it was a really mean mean-spirited
thing to say I thought I would never
ever say anything like that to anybody it's a
very conceited thing yeah I almost feel like
it's a hazing and that's the only way I can think
of it is like you've got to have a bunch of those
to just keep you absolutely I'm going to keep
getting because absolutely yeah it's it's
they do happen they do what
do you think it was about
take back that excited producers and financiers
well it definitely helped to have mickey attached
I also think that in the marketplace
now I think thrillers like that
thriller horror films that have a decent
hook to them that can maybe you get a good
attachment cast wise and that can be made
fairly cheap will definitely help your cause
I you know you want to write something an
obviously minimal location I mean I always think
a saw which is just brilliant because it actually
was a short film which they then expand into a
feature but it was really obviously took place
mostly in one location take back had multiple
locations but it's a smaller indie action film
that was able to be confined to the small town
so I think that definitely helped
it and but a film that's got like a
I would say a budget of between half a million
and maybe one and a half million two million
not a lot of locations and and still is a solid
you got a solid 85 90 page script to work from
and again you're not there's not a
huge lot of of of location changes
and not a huge cast I think people are
and and again you get a good attachment
could be anybody who will bring money into these
foreign territories and pre-sell the film you're
going to be in good shape easier said than done
yes but definitely it's it's not impossible
and I will say real quick I think based on what
we were taught you made an excellent point before
when we were talking off-camera about the the
you have these sort of the the huge studio budget
films that are like 300 million and then you
have these smaller budgets like take back etc
that are going anywhere between half a million
to low seven figures there's really not a lot in
between that's happening unless maybe you're at
netflix or amazon but the studios are generally
they're they're they're trying to hit it out of
the park every time within these huge budgets
and the smaller films are being made in the
way take back is with foreign financiers
it's not all foreign financiers there
was a mix but definitely different
conglomeration of different producers and
financiers and production companies and then but
the the in between the 30 40 50 60 million dollar
films they're not really being made as much unless
again there's there's a major actor attached
and they are doing it maybe independently of
the studio but I'm sure they exist but it's like
we talked about before it seems like there is this
big gap between what's the reality and of what's
happening now with as far as movies being made
how did you get mickey work attached so early
that was all mike hatton the producer he uh
he hadn't I believe he
had knew mickey's agent or manager and was able
to get it to him that way I believe or he had a
connection somehow and was able to get mickey
the script and mickey signed on pretty quickly
he signed on very quickly james russo had already
been attached so and james and mickey I believe
knew each other too that may have helped
a little bit but I think mickey was mickey
was the big get and that was again done through
mike's mutual a mutual acquaintance of my cats
why didn't mickey work leave the project
because we paid him a lot of money
well I know that the project was sort of in
flux it was for a while okay we had him there
and he to to his credit he's he
stayed he he was staying part
he wanted to be involved
the his character is also a
takes care of he runs an animal saying a no kill
dog shelter in the film that's his character
what his character does and mickey as we know
is a big he's I think a peta spokes person so
it would it had a lot of elements that I think
he appreciated and that kept him there for a bet
and the fact that we paid him a
lot of effing money to be in it
that definitely helped that definitely helped
what kind of conversations did you have with
mickey rourke about the script and his character
I didn't have any conversations with him i
the the script so
this was an interesting one
because there was no I was paid
but I wasn't but it wasn't as a
spec and it was not a work for hire
I was paid as a portion of the budget so
basically
once my I turned in my pre-production draft they
the director christian and the actors kind of
took it from there I really didn't have a lot of
I'm didn't have any involvement in the
pre-production planning or discussion
my role was fulfilled is I fulfilled my role as a
writer and and that was and that was how it went
so they made changes to the script and and again
it was there it was their script to make changes
too because I had been compensated and and I think
there it'll turn out well with what they what they
come up with I'm optimistic but it was but I never
I met Gillian and Michael Jai White on set I had
known I had met James Rousseau a few years earlier
when we were sort of getting in the we were in the
infant stages of getting the film up and going
but I unfortunately did not meet mickey or
speak to him he had more direct conversation with
christian the director and mike the producer how
did you get the producer Mike Hatton on board so
the gentleman who was the lead producer initially
we were he was in the he was in
the market for finding a director
he found christian christian worked with Mike
Hatton and they were producing partners mike was
still acting he was at that point I mean he was
in the green book and he still he's still in a
bunch of films prior and after green book but mike
to mike and christian really took to the material
and because mike was christian's producing
partner they came and we're both involved in the
in the process from then on and and mike I can't
say enough good things about him like his energy
his support and again enthusiasm and chris's too
but mike's mike's like the energizer bunny he's
he he's go go go and and I really I can
appreciate that about him he's a hustler and
you need somebody like that I think especially
navigating in in a more in the indie world even
even in a studio film world to have to have a
guy like that on your side who's hustling is
trying to get things done and doing 300 things at
once and getting them done and getting them done
well efficiently I hope to make more films
with with mike down the line I really do
I really do but we'll see he's he's he's
working on three things at once literally he's
he they just finished two more films since
take back and with with really good casts
so they just he's always got something going on
as does chris where were you emotionally and what
happened when you heard that the film may or may
not happen oh it was definitely over the years as
a roller coaster I've had some of those other some
other experiences like that where films were on
the verge I it was it was it was always teetering
on that line of will it or won't it for a while
and I think I became so and again it
wasn't it really just had to do with the
lining up the money it wasn't that I was I didn't
think that micah chris was enthusiastic I just
thought it just came down to dollars and cents
and so but I became very just sort of immune
to the the roller coaster of emotions and just
sort of accepted everything as it was and just
was optimistic that it eventually would happen it
was just a matter of timing like everything else
so something that you practiced early on or
you learn to develop I just it's comes with age
and maturation and and my martial arts training
again I'm an impatient person by nature
but I've definitely tempered it learn to
temper it over the years and just keep
everything in perspective and there's just
so many things that are out of your control
I tell that to my wife all the time it
was like with with any aspect of life
and filmmaking obviously is no different you just
it requires such a tremendous amount of patience
look I have a film another film now that I've
been sitting on for four years which I think is a
you know very timely concept with everything we're
going through it was timely four years ago but
trying to get everybody in sync with everyone's
schedule and I don't blame anyone everyone's got
their own thing they're doing but it it definitely
gets to the point and I'm still guilty of being
of being like what in the effort we doing what's
going on here it can be very it can be very just
you you really have to learn to I
would say if it's if it's a year
that's one thing but we're when you go on three
four years and you're still waiting it's like
okay you start to get a little like you start to
get a little wary about where everything is and
just hope that again your number's called but
again so many things are out of your control
and again that was a teacher at NYU that said if
you stick with it eventually that was my manager
your manager okay if you if you keep if
you keep at it eventually your number
comes up I learned that about I learned that
about my wife I was single for many years
and I would get frustrated that I was like I just
like to meet a nice girl and somebody who I really
felt that connection with and it took a long time
but eventually my number got called and we've been
actually we just we've been together four years of
as of yesterday and oh great we met four years ago
yesterday and then we've been married for close
to two years congratulations thank you very much
but it it it just I think it I think it's just
look some people have it sooner other people it
happens a little bit later and you just I think if
you can just stay optimistic and stay focused and
and keep moving forward and not get discouraged
and it's so hard to get discouraged it's so hard
but I really believe that if it's
you're truly passionate about it
and at the same time you have you have that talent
and you have a story multiple great stories to
tell but just take one just takes one it'll it'll
eventually it will eventually get you there I do
believe that I'm living proof of that but again
it's it's not getting discouraged so many people
actors writers directors everyone comes to how
hollywood is is is is meant to discourage you
it's here to discourage you
it's it's the development
development people are are paid to say
no they're paid to say no to to writers
so and it's so easy to just get discouraged and
turned off by that and we all have dealt with it
but I will say that if if if you stick
to your guns you keep honing your craft
you stay encouraged not discouraged
and you keep marching forward sorry for
for the cliches but it's true and you have and you
do have a talent for it even a modicum of talent
if you have it and you keep nurturing it and
you and again eventually I do I do think I think
it was I do think it was aaron sorkin I believe
who said good material eventually finds its way
i believe it was him yeah it sounds like I watched
the master class with him it was excellent I feel
like you might have said that as well and in
a sense not not to cheapen dating with with
the film industry but there's some similarities
in that in la the dating world is so much about
oh how do they look on paper absolutely where'd
they go to school what are they how do they look
at first what's this oh yeah what are some of them
sometimes people don't even care about that they
just want to know what do they do for a living
yeah absolutely and so that equates the same way
in the film industry who's attached what what is
this and it's like the same now I need something
bigger I need this I need better but then that
one special thing i.e or the special person
you can somehow find that but it takes a long
time I think yeah it it sometimes can sometimes
it's quick sometimes it's it doesn't
take as long sometimes it takes longer
and again I'm not saying look I mean
people may read the read take back or
watch tape back eventually be like what but
we've all seen those movies we're like what
were they thinking how did this thing get
made I'm guilty of saying that I am but
I still think that there has to be a couple
of things the the the the script has to be
somewhat decent all right it has to be legible
it has to have some kind of emotion tied into it
and again you don't know how how it could just
affect and somebody reacts luckily christian mike
both really liked the script they dug it and they
were like okay we're let's let's get rocking on
this the producer who took it to them was the same
way like they took to it and again I had a number
of people who are lined up who did really like
the script and and were high on it so that was
I had that going for me but sometimes look it it
may again bring it back to the french connection
I think that went to 25 different places before
somebody said yes really yeah I believe don't
quote me but I believe it went to every studio
in town production companies it went all around
and there's a handful of other screenplays that
went around it it was and it wasn't like the the
a bidding war for them and you saw and you saw
what what what amazing movies came out of that and
again I'm not saying ours is going to be on that
level but all it takes is one person to say yes
20 people may say no 25 in the case of
french connection say 24 said no and then
I believe it was um oh zanac I believe was oh okay
dick zanac said yes when he was running things
over there he was young he was the wonderkind
and his father daryl had run fox and he said yes
it's it's that's it and if you're and I was
fortunate that that happened and I hope it happens
again I believe you said you've been writing
scripts ever since you were at NYU yeah how many
years did you go even though 20. okay I optioned
I did option a number of scripts along the way
and iowa again I had I was fortunate that some
of my scripts served as good samples to get me
into meetings with a number of fairly
well-known producers and network execs
but this was the first group that I was able to
really close it took a while 20 years 20 years
20 years and I'm grateful that it that it's
here I'm grateful that I do have the credit
but it did take a while and again I'm
one of those and I'm sure many guys
and girls who who have had a lot
of near misses with their scripts
no doubt no no and and I and I was fortunate
that a lot of those people really did like
my work that I submitted it was always like we
really like your script not this but what else
do you have and I'd say I have this and they're
like yeah and it just didn't always sync up
I did I did have some really wonderful meetings
with some again some fairly well-known people but
in the end it just yeah it this this this happened
finally it was wonderful well we always hear about
20 under 25 and and if you look at was it
steve larsen from the the trilogy series the
girl with the dragon tattoo yeah I think he was
almost 50 I know he's 50 when he passed away but
yeah he'd been working on at least one book I'm
not sure yeah what he died I think they they came
out after he died he never even saw the success
right and he had been a journalist and doing
other things and and so it took a very long time
but he was just very dedicated to he wanted to
do it right yeah there was a gentleman who just
I believe sold he was I think he's in his 40s
and he had something similar happen where he was
like just living hand to mouth he had a family
I believe he's maybe even irish and I think
he sold a he wrote a book that sold for a
few million dollars oh wow and he yeah there
definitely have been yeah there there are and I
certainly don't I I try to stay young so I don't
feel my age but no it was it was just definitely
just just sticking just staying on
the path and and sticking with it and
again this isn't like a major studio film but
it's still I'm proud of where what happened with
it I'm proud that it got made it's not easy
and especially during the time of kovitz so
I definitely take some pride in that and if it
leads to great things that would be wonderful
but I definitely did feel a sense of
accomplishment when I got that paycheck and
it's the cameras were rolling it really felt
great it really felt great and again I hope to
continue writing and having other stuff
produced we'll see remains to be seen
at what point in the 20 years did
you say I'm not giving up I would say
again I was I was repped I did have a literary
manager for a long time who got my work out there
and I felt like over the years we got close on a
few things and it was it's obviously like a tease
so I never really felt like I was I was ready to
give up I always knew that I just have a passion
of burning passion to write so I in my mind
I was like look I'm going to keep doing this
and I will get there I did have some
very supportive people not certainly not
ass kissers telling me just keep going
and it was encouraging and I think
really once I got this script and the other
script that I mentioned that's sort of with
attachments I think once those started coming
in the last few years that was like okay
it started feeling like okay this will eventually
happen it there we're gonna go through well we
obviously went through some discouraging times
in a little bit of the emotional roller coaster
but we were we were able to I felt eventually we
were gonna we were gonna get there so I'd say in
the last few years I also I also started about
five years ago I started writing novels as well
and I have a I do have a agent a book agent
and he's always been very encouraging and he's
he has one of our books that he's shopping
now at a lot of the major publishers so
you know it's it's I feel encouraged by
that as well but yeah I never I never really
I of course there were there are moments
like am I gonna am I gonna quit do I did I
get discouraged yes but I never felt like I was
gonna quit what did the script sale teach you
humility perseverance
um
yeah it's uh
when I when I saw that when I saw the the it
was actually deposit don't tell my account um
you know I got a little misty-eyed but I think
I had been through so much with the again
over the years the just again people
liking your work you're thinking you
were close to something but it was when
it was it was I hate to say anti-climactic
and I got a little misty-eyed but I was
like okay this is great but I think I'd been
I had been at it so long that I was like
just it was it was it was definitely a uh
um I definitely was humbled I was I
definitely felt humbled by it I really did
humbled in the sense that you stuck with
it because you loved it or humbled in the
sense that your number was both yeah I did I felt
again it was just the it was it was a lot of years
and it's I the funny thing is the thing
that went to me is like oh well maybe
this also could be the last time but I did it
I did it and that was great that was that was
what I took from it I savored it but I just
I just I guess my I wasn't like I jumped down
up and down of this around the
house and popped the champagne cork
as much as I had always envisioned that right for
years like I'm gonna go ape crap here and and just
do cartwheels down the street risky
business right exactly exactly yeah take my
take my neighbor's porsche out first but no it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't really like that at
all it was again just anticlimactic in a lot
of regards but again I still left feeling very
just humbled by the time in the experience and and
feeling that perseverance that okay this is real I
made it here and so if it's the only thing that I
ever do I still I still have it on I still have it
I still have a credit I still have
it there and that was wonderful
and I hope there's I hope there are more we'll see
that was my next question how confident are
you that you will get another movie made
well
i feel that the other film other
script that I have is again timely
I feel very connected to it I think that it's
it's got some really terrific elements in it
but it comes down to dollars and cents and if
the money's there I think we're in good shape
I it's it's also just always gauging
people's levels of commitment
in these things and I feel
like they are committed but
yeah I think it comes down to attaching people and
and and and getting everyone working I think it's
gelling everyone together in order to to push
it through that's what I that's what I'm hoping
but at this point yeah it's a matter of getting
getting the the investment into it that one and
a half to three mil it'll take to to get there
and then hopefully it's it leads to you know
snapping the clap soon sooner rather than
later but we'll see so going back to that
question I had said about if you were going to
teach someone to write a screenplay that sells
the first question probably would be why do
you even want to do it in the first place
because that same person may not stick with that
absolutely for the 20 years but if you love it
yeah if it if it's a burning passion
and it gets you up in the morning and
you just enjoy the process and the
highs and lows that come with it
then go for it if it's something where
there's nothing wrong with giving it a
try but if it's something where you're
not really it's like anything else it's
it's what it's a it's malcolm gladwell's a 10
000 hour rule right where you you put in your
ten thousand hours I don't see become an expert
but you become pretty proficient at something
it's just like that but I think also with that ten
thousand hours you really have to love doing it
it really has to get you going and you you really
it's it's essentially it is like uh your mistress
it's my mistress now was my girlfriend
for many years she became my mission
running became my mistress after I got married and
my wife my wife coexists with her pretty well but
but yeah it's definitely something you just have
to have an unbridled passion for and and you seek
to get up every morning and it it's there and
you it's like and it's like going to the gym and
working out it's working your riding muscles every
day just going to the gym going to the writing gym
is it the goldfinch donna tart take her 12 years
to finish that did it maybe is it a sequel so
another she had another one there I think both
turned into films I know the name goldfinch was
turned into a film but if I maybe but yeah 12
years yeah that's dedication and she just loved
she loved the process absolutely I mean there's I
think william goldman he was he was younger when
he because he was a novelist when he was a stat
he established himself probably in his late 20s 30
ish as a but I don't think his first film
was made until he was maybe in his mid 30s
so yeah there's there's definitely
maybe he's not the best example but
there's definitely I feel like writers
or artists or etc out there who are
sometimes it just takes them a little longer
to gestate and find find the story that that is
gonna they're gonna make their mark with or or
at least break through with that piece of work
did you write every day for 20 years almost I
would say close to it not I there were times
obviously some weekends or when I had my daughter
it wasn't always the easiest thing but there were
times where I'd get up early before she was awake
and especially when she was a baby super early and
work now she sleeps late so but no I've I usually
I at this at this stage there occasionally I work
on the weekends but generally I confine it to
monday through friday for the most part so that
20 years you would get up at quarter to six not
every day but I would I would make I would make
it and then I was working when I was working I
worked at fox again as a research analyst for a
number of years I would use I'd be up early before
I'd have to work and then I usually work during my
lunch break so I tried always try to get in at
least maybe like three hours and then I would I
would work sometimes on the weekend definitely
before I was married but now I feel like
I feel like I'm getting hitting most of my goals
during the week again working smarter not harder
if five years from now pass and you still haven't
made more money from screenwriting will you keep
writing screenplays I think it depends I
really enjoyed working on novels it's um
you know the great thing about working novels
and having that again we we talked about the
intellectual property earlier that so many of
so many of the films that are being made now
are based on ip and now that I have
really two properties that are ip
I feel that and I actually I do have
confidence that one of them will be sold soon
hopefully both but one I think
again unlike wood is close
I would love to turn both of
those into films but we'll see
um I will always be writing I'm a senior
because I still need to work and pay my bills
I'm a senior copywriter in
at a company out here in la
so I am always writing no matter what copy
novels scripts and they're all very different
not to take anything not to be undone but
it's still for me the process is still
is copywriting novels scripts you still need
to do your research you still need to have
a great headline or a log line or and you need to
have structure to what you're writing it really
so much of writing does follow that those those
that similar pattern and that's how I work anyway
so I'm satiated with the with being able to
write every day now which is wonderful that said
yeah I would never if if an opportunity came
up to write a great story or if I found a
time to develop a script that I thought
would make a really great film absolutely um
so I would never I would never not do it I think
though at this point the movie business has become
again it's it's just changed so
drastically even the last five years so
I feel like again a lot of writers are again
writing books or back and forth or writing tv
or are back and forth between novels and
tv and film they're bouncing all around so
but I think they're picking their opportunities as
they come up rather than just being a screenwriter
straight screenwriter and I think writers are
diversifying all the time which is great so yeah
I think creativity is creativity I think if you're
either you're writing for a health and wellness
brand or you're working for you're writing a
novel about world war ii I think they all sort of
feed into each other with the process and so
yeah I know that's sort of the long answer but
no I would I would completely be open to it but
I also feel like I have a whole array of other
creative projects in my portfolio at this point
so if it lends itself to that then absolutely
right and you're absolutely right I think
you said that either before the interview
or or during just that so many adaptations are
are appearing I mean what the hillbilly allergies
right the queen's gambit was based on a book from
actually interesting story about that gentleman
he it was published in 1983 and he died in 1984.
oh and now it's being made almost 40 years
later oh wow so it's it's definitely a um
you know there there's there is a tremendous
push for again the adaptation and basing
current material and previous material
again whether it's graphic novel
comic novel like we just discussed podcast
anything art a news article magazine article
and it's for for whatever reason I feel
like the the folks who are who are in
who are at a lot of these companies or these
production companies who still have sway
they feel that that it there's some there's an air
of legitimacy to putting that forward and there's
not as many original series or ideas really
being put forth like they used to be yeah and
I don't know if it's just because our attention
spans are so much shorter so like novels used to
be such a thing and letter writing and all that
and now right okay if that's actually a success
then we can turn it into I don't know it's yeah
it's it's it's really true it's really true it's
they movie books are are actually the the I
believe what I read recently that books are being
sold at still at a pretty high rate their their
book sales are up obviously when the pandemic
certainly helped out and I don't know many of
those are ebooks versus actual hard copies but
they're still reading people are still reading and
I think that there is so much material out there
that they're drawing from and oftentimes they
view certain material like I said as a legitimate
source there's already that built-in audience
even if it's 5 000 people who have read it it's
still they and it was it's made by an imprint one
of harpercollins 300 imprints and it's small it's
got us but it's still it still has a really good
hook and it will it it has a built-in fan base to
an extent and then they decide okay well we can
we can make this into a film I don't know I don't
I again I don't know the mindset I think again it
is it does have something to do with they want to
max obviously like any other business they want to
maximize their profit and they see if they already
have a built-in fan base that's going only going
to increase sales and and it's it makes sense
right and barfly was that with mickey rourked
wasn't that based on I may have been uhkowski okay
it may have been I wasn't sure yes it was okay it
was may stoner bukowski yes then bukowski wrote
about it in hollywood I think if it's the same
film yeah and he talked about his process so yeah
yeah yeah I think I don't know very colorfully
described yeah exactly exactly yeah he was a
he was a character in fact totem I think as
well about his jobs yeah with Matt Dillion
and lily yeah exactly so it's been going
on for a while but yeah there was that
built-in audience and then absolutely there
we go absolutely and and you again you see
like Hillbilly Elegy or I know where the
crawdad saying is going to be coming out
that's all got major studios attached to it but
you're talking about however many hundreds of
thousands or millions of copies sold and people
are gonna say hey I love that book I'm subscribe
or when we do go back to theaters they'll oh
yeah they'll they'll go they'll go pay to see it
for sure yeah I hope that opportunity is
still around I hope so too I hope so too.